ce sera un bâtiment tout en bois du sol
au plafond une nouvelle structure au
sein du technocentre renault de
guyancourt son nom odyssée une
appellation choisie par les
collaborateurs du site
un chantier démarré cet été avec la pose
des premiers piliers en bois en octobre
dernier
vous voyez à cet endroit là l'assemblage
des poteaux des poutres et des planchers
qui se fait de façon simultanée donc de
façon très rapide
l'ensemble et lycées là c'est la partie
qui va encore durer un mois et demi à
peu près pour élever la principale
structure
ensuite on va y apposer les façades ce
nouveau bâtiment de 12 mille mètres
carrés accueillera près de 700
collaborateurs
il s'inscrit dans le large projet de
rénovation du site
le programme efficience du technocentre
renault aujourd'hui tout a changé dans
les modes de travail en particulier dans
les modes de travail de l'ingénierie et
on a besoin de se mettre en lien avec
toutes les nouveautés du mode de
fonctionnement et l'organisation dans
l'espace doit être en phase avec la
manière dont les gens travaillent
le nouvel immeuble va nous donner 700
places de plus qui va nous permettre d
idées entre guillemets la ruche pour
accélérer les travaux dans la ruche
effectivement les mobiliers innovants
que nous avions présenté il ya quelques
semaines seront dans ce bâtiment ce site
de recherche et développement a ouvert
ses portes en 1998 il couvre une surface
de 150 hectares et emploie près de onze
mille personnes
un site important pour l'économie du
territoire
la livraison du bâtiment est prévue pour
l'été prochain les collaborateurs
intégreront le site entre septembre et
novembre 2020